à plus de 350 mille votes sur télé
loisirs.fr ça a été
voilà et non et kelly mais dvd ou d'être
meilleur chroniqueur s'invite comme dit
à peine un petit empire us va écouter
c'est grâce à vous vous êtes incroyables
si julien benneteau qui dit merci aux
gens et j'apprécie les secours toutes
les personnes qui ont voté pour moi je
m'y attendais mais vraiment mais pas du
tout mais absolument pas c'est maxime
qui m'a envoyé un petit message me dit
en me disant ça des fois je le croyais
pas j'ai même cru que les trucs et un
beau salon sur le futur je voulais aussi
remercier cyril parce que c'est grâce à
jonathan celui-là bravo droit sur elle a
pas eu la palme d'or non plus ses traits
d'abord dans franchement apporté aux six
mois autant et bah je voulais je vous
dis la vérité en vrai la palme d'or je
m'emballe agathe mais oui bon [ __ ]
plus parce que je m'en reste plus qu'une
l'accident c'est un truc de tri car les
autres
bonne nouvelle ça c'est la france voilà
une bonne nouvelle à arthur a eu 2 % oui
mais bon ils fêtaient aux professionnels
aux audiences bien il le sait
ça va elle même ça il le sait sa
meilleure animatrice valérie bénaïm des
talents mots parce qu'on est très pressé
et dans un mot sur les ours vous dire
merci merci à toi syrie parce que ça
fait messi parce que cette année c'est
tu m'a permis d'être devant de dire aux
gens je les aimais et les gens ils me
l'ont rendu à 1%
il a pris un petit coup de peau de
chamois pour terminer les boules
chroniqueurs la vérité c'est lui qui a
eu l'idée de me faut de me produire dans
cette émission y compris donc vraiment
et vous pouvez dire merci à juger à
combes et de cette variation maximale or
là c'est écouter et vous aussi je ne m'y
attendais mais je suis hyper content que
ce soit vous by vote dans la maison du
père noël et ça m'a fait très plaisir
et merci comme quoi on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir des manifs à lower pourrait-on
maxime bravo mme akharbach s'est mal
passé je n'ai pas dans les bagages
il mérite il faisait 10 appels par
l'enjeu allez merci alors elle s'est
montré bon perdant tout le monde
c'est à tout le monde me rassure alors
je vais le reverra pas vraiment plus
ancien maire il symbolise tout soit on
voit ce qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient
[Applaudissements]
aller ni je pars dans la montagne ont
fait savoir les deux minutes car au oui
non mais c'est bientôt la fin d'année en
plus on va commencer la dixième année
c'est vrai je suis là depuis le 1er
avril 2010 et tout le monde de façon
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde est
là depuis le début tellement est une
grande famille moi je suis ravi on se
marre de plus en plus et à boulot comme
ça où on va au travail en sachant qu'on
va se marrer français bonheur total avec
le docteur sarsa bonheur de tous les
jours ces longs mois alors merci et je
vais remercier voilà theater et tous les
gens qui ont fait voilà que voilà c'est
ça qui va le mettre dans ma chambre
veolia voilà donc merci à vous merci
merci